[Music]
we want our freedom
and we want it now
we do not want to go to jail
but we will go to jail if this sister is
a prize we must pay for love
brotherhood and true peace that was john
lewis
at the march on washington in 1963 he
called on americans to
wake up welcome back to cbs this morning
former u.n ambassador andrew young knew
lewis for decades and considered him a
friend
they fought in the civil rights movement
together with dr martin luther king jr
andrew young helped draft the civil
rights act of 1964
and later became the first
african-american to serve as
ambassador to the united nations he was
also a u.s
congressman and of course the mayor of
atlanta andrew young joins us from
atlanta good morning mr ambassador
thanks for being with us
i know you met with uh with john lewis
just
last week can you tell us what that last
meeting was like
well i want to forget that last meeting
because i saw then that he was weak
and i'd never seen him weak before john
lewis
when i saw him was always the
the calm quiet power
of humility integrity and
and determination he didn't say much uh
but when he said a word everybody
listened
[Music]
because he was willing to put his life
on the line for any word he spoke
yeah he demonstrated that over and over
again
you've said that humility was his real
power
which is very interesting because a lot
of people think humility is a weakness
well that's true but you have to
remember back in 1961
when snick was formed you had a hundred
uh young leaders from all over the south
and
uh marion barry who became mayor of uh
washington uh was one of those leaders
the
the women all
powerful and yet he emerged as the
leader of that group and i think the
reason was
that he he didn't fight for it he wasn't
lobbying for it he was just
he was being himself and he was one
person that everybody could trust
the same thing happened to martin luther
king in 1955
uh there were people who were fighting
to be leaders
of the montgomery improvement
association he was in the back of the
church
running the memorial machine printing
the flyers for the next day's
demonstration
and when they had a log jam
they decided that he was the one that
they could trust
i think humility is an underrated
power and influence in our lives when we
think about the power
of you add that i apologize when you add
go ahead that integrity and
determination
to his humility he's not going anywhere
he's not giving
up uh he's going to keep getting in good
trouble
when we talk about that good trouble he
loves even his enemies
and i doubt that there's anybody in
congress
that has more friends on the opposite
side of the eye
on the other side of the aisle than john
lewis he got along with everybody
because he respected everybody he loved
everybody
and he saw the worth in everyone as a
child of god
ambassador young while we're thinking
about congressman lewis's personal
qualities
the quality of resilience comes to mind
his philosophy of non-violence was
tested and tested severely more than
once he was left unconscious in a pool
of his own blood
how did he remain so resilient and so
optimistic
well i don't think his optimist optimism
so much
is his faith and determination i think
we have faith in this country
we have faith in humanity we have faith
in god
we know this is my father's world
dr king said the moral arc of the
universe is long but it strip
bends toward justice but we have to bend
that
that moral arc and um i think
it's faith in god it's faith in the
country
and his faith in that even in us flawed
and you know foolish human beings
uh there is the capacity for us to come
together as one
in a time of crisis and we've done that
in our lifetime my lifetime going back
to the second world war
yeah when the coin gets tough
but tough get going and on the subject
of getting going the last time
we spoke to congressman lewis on this
show he said that the death of george
floyd and the movement that followed was
another step
on the long road toward freedom how do
you judge our journey on that road are
we any closer
today to dr king's dream well we're much
closer because
i think the american people saw george
floyd die
just as they saw john get beat up
on the bridge and just as they saw
a little nude girl walking down the
streets of
vietnam and decided that when they see
this kind of
inhumanity they don't want to be a part
of it
and so the american people said that's
not the america i believe in
i do not believe in policemen killing
innocent
men who are no threat that's not america
and so it was america that rose up all
colors all classes
i've been impressed with the way the
business community even
has realized that they are
also a part of a system that has not
exercised the full rights and potential
of all of the citizens even if you look
at it as
a marketplace
the market is at the bottom of the
pyramid
and we see the essential workers
that are essential not only as workers
but they're essential as consumers
it doesn't matter what color they are
we've got to bring this economy back
together and we've got to bring the
uh the world economy back together yeah
and we've got to deal with all of those
things that have
held us back and john was willing to do
that
all his life yeah ambassador young a man
who at one time was inspired by john
lewis
continuing to inspire with your own
words today thank you very much for
being with us
thanks and god bless you